up
okay it looks like we're live
welcome to week two
um i'll put an agenda up for today
by the way i feel like i should mention
something that uh i mentioned this
last week and it's kind of been eating
at me so i said that i
don't have child care and that's not
entirely true what
what is the situation is that my partner
and i have
child care outside of our home in the
morning and then in the afternoon we
trade off taking care of our daughters
so
my daughter is at home but it's not as
though i'm leaving her completely
unsupervised during this time
in fact my partner is taking care of her
um
but she might wander in at some point so
in fact i kind of hope she does
because i want people to get to beat her
but
hopefully it won't be an everyday
occurrence all right
so on the agenda for today
we're going to recap
of what happens before
relation from last time today we're
going to talk about
partial orders and total orders
lamport plots
and vector clocks
i think that should be enough for today
all right so um so last time we covered
a lot
the happens before relationship is the
particular thing that i
would like to recap uh so could somebody
recap the definition of the happens
before relation for me
you can either shout it out or type
something into zulu
when do you know that two events are
related by happens people
good okay so there's kind of three cases
right
so if you have two events that
are in the same process
and a happens before b in that process
then you know a happens before b
generally
the second case is
if a is ascend
and b is the corresponding receive
then you know it happens before b
and the third case uh is what makes the
relation transitive
so then
if you had for instance
a message send that was event a i
receive
uh the corresponding receive call that b
and c here actually let's call this one
c
and this one b
then you know what happens before b
because uh these
uh these two events have are related by
happens before and so are these
or you or maybe it would look like this
here again a happens before b
so those are the pieces of the happens
before relation and you can put them
together
so if you've got a bunch of events you
can use this definition
to figure out what happened before what
or at least you could if you had an
efficient way to compute what's in the
happens before relation so we'll talk
about that today
before getting to that uh let's
let's just uh put up a bunch of events
and
remind ourselves how we can talk about
events being related or not related so
if we had three machines
or three nodes let's just put a whole
bunch of
events and messages here
okay so um what are some of the
relationships between events in this
picture
um for example uh if i were to pick out
a and e are those events related by the
happens before relation
sure yeah because we can follow this
line here from a to b
and then e comes after b on the same
process so we have
a happens before e
what about
d and a
no those ones were not related so
if you look at a here if you try to
follow what are all the places you can
get from a well you can get to b
and you can get to e but you can't
follow this line backwards
you could get f and g um so
we can't we don't we don't have the a
happens before d
and then similarly for d we can't get to
a
from from d either so it's not the case
that a happens before d
nor is it the case that d happens before
a
so instead we would say that a and d are
concurrent
and sometimes that's written like this
so in general if you have a whole bunch
of events here
a b c d e f g h so you have this set of
events right
and you have this relation that relates
some of the events to other events um
but
the there's not necessarily going to be
a relationship
under the happens before relationship
for every pair of events that you can
pick out here
mathematically speaking what would you
call
that happens before relation does anyone
know
yeah it's transitive for sure it is
transitive relation
um but there's a name for this kind of
relation
good yeah somebody just mentioned it's a
it's a partial order
so does anybody here know what the
definition of a partial order is
let's go over it together
by the way it's going to turn out that
happens before relation is actually not
quite a partial order according to the
rules that i'm about to give you so
we'll see why in just a moment
so partial order is actually two things
glued together
so first it's a set
let's call it s
together with
a binary relation
which is often
written using something like this that
looks like less than or equals
that lets you compare things from the
set x
and has the following croppings
help me out here what are the properties
that the binary relation in a partial
order is supposed to have
anyone know
i'll give you the first one for free
reflexivity so that means
for every element of s
let's call it a
a is related to itself
what else what else is going to be true
about the binary relation and partial
curve you don't know you can look it up
on wikipedia
ah somebody just said okay somebody said
symmetry
interesting so symmetry would be a
property of it if there's an
equivalence relation but it's not going
to be an equivalence relation
anti-symmetry but
so what does anti-symmetry mean
let's say that i have
some a and b that are members of the set
and let's say that
if i want to claim that
if a is related to b by the relation
and b is related to a
what has to be true about a and b then
yeah that's right good
so a has to be equal to b so if i'm
going to go around saying that a
is less than equal to b and b is also
less than or equal to a
well the only way that can be true is if
a and b
are the same so that's what
anti-symmetry says
and the last part
transitivity which we actually already
talked about quite a bit in the context
of happens before
but it's something that's actually true
of every partial order and transitivity
just says that
for all a b and c
that happen to be elements of this set
as then
if a is related to b and b is related to
c
then a is related to c
so there are lots and lots and lots and
lots of relations that are partial
orders
uh it's a pretty ubiquitous notion that
comes up
all over the place in computer science
happens before it's just a particular
one let's glance back at the definition
of partial order here and just try to
spot check to see whether it makes sense
to say that happens before is a partial
order
and i'll give you a spoiler which is
that it's actually not quite
okay so is the happens before relation
of partial order well
first of all we need to be talking about
a set right so when we talk about
happens before what set are we talking
about
that's right yeah we're talking about
the set of events so
just like in this picture we just saw
here
we have a set of events here um how many
events one two three four five six seven
eight we have eight events here
um so that we'll be talking about the
set of events in a particular execution
so back to the definition of partial
order
so in this case the set just looks like
this
looks like it's set to me
okay and the relation that relates those
events
that happens before a relation is
supposed to have all of these
properties well yeah let's take the easy
one first right
is the happens before relation
transitive
that's right yeah absolutely it is it's
right there in the definition of happens
before that we just looked at
so check
we got that covered what about
anti-symmetry
well this says okay so for all a and b
that are in the set so
pick out any two events from there this
says if a is related to b
and b is related to a then then a plus b
well
so let's see if you picked out two
events from here let's say like
d and e okay if d
happens before e and e
happens before dv does that even make
sense to talk about like is there any
situation
in which one event happens before the
other and also the opposite
like going back to this picture here
does it make any sense to say that
here i mean it's clear if i'm looking at
this that d happens before e
um but does it ever make sense to say
like one event happens before the other
and then also the opposite
no yeah that's not possible
so what that means in terms of the
definition of partial order for us
is this is actually what we call
vacuously true
so we we have this anti-symmetry
property for the happens before relation
okay so we have those two criteria
what about reflexivity given an event
any event here let's let's say g
does it make sense to say g happens
before g
it doesn't make sense to me what would
that even mean
if i were to say g happens before g or a
happens before a
no it's not clear what it would mean for
an event to happen before itself
so this is not true so this here these
uh
these check marks and x's here are
particularly to do with the happens
before relation
so we're checking to see whether happens
before is actually a partial order
according to these criteria
and it turns out that it's not because
it's not reflexive
so happens before is not quite a partial
order
rather it's what's known as an
irreflexive partial order
so when you're talking about an
irreflexive partial order um
it's sometimes also called a strict
partial order but i prefer to use the
word irreflexive
uh just to emphasize the fact that
reflexivity is the property that we lose
so happens before is an irreflexive
partial order um but you'll often hear
people
including me just saying it's a partial
order
so i'm letting you know that it does
in fact it is in fact not quite a
partial order according to
the definition of partial order it's
fine to say
partial order as long as people know
what you mean
uh but i wanted to give the real
definition of partial order here because
it's such a ubiquitous
concept and we're going to see it so
often
that it's useful to know so
why don't we talk about something that
is in fact an example of a partial order
truly a partial order and not merely an
irreflexive potion
so a good example of that
is set containment
or set inclusion as it's sometimes
called
so in this case the set
s would be
the set of all subsets of a set
so let's say that the set that we're
talking about is
abc like that so then s would be the set
of all subsets of that so we've got like
the empty set and then the set
containing a
set containing b set containing c
the set with a and b
a and c
b and c and then the set containing all
three
so that's our set s this set has
one two three four five six seven eight
elements and we can order those
uh by set inclusion
which would look something like this so
at the bottom
you've got the empty set
one level up from that you've got the
sets containing a b and c
above that you have the two element sets
and then
at the top
the set of all three classic example of
a partial order
so why is it a partial order because
not because those three properties are
true right
so reflexivity anti-symmetry and
transitivity
so for example
if we were to just look at a particular
element here of s
uh that element
is a subset of itself not a strict
subset but it's a subset of itself
the same is true for anything else here
it's considered a subset of itself
so we have reflexivity
what about anti-symmetry
uh somebody just asked in chat how is a
set of three letters of parts in order
well
so this here
is the set that we're taking subsets of
so the partial order
is on this set s which is the set of all
subsets of that
so this set s that has eight elements
here
that set can be ordered by set inclusion
and so what we're doing is we're
defining this uh set inclusion order
on the set s which is the set of subsets
of this set up here
so we just looked at this relation
relationship which was reflexivity
uh what about anti-symmetry so
anti-symmetry says
that uh in this case it would be
if something is a subset of something
else and also the opposite
uh then they have to be equal uh
so yeah so in this case for example
um i can't i can't come up with anything
here
where something is a subset of something
else and also the opposite
is true without them being the same
so
for example the set containing a
and b is a subset of the set containing
a and b
and also the opposite is true we'll
notice that they're the same
and that would have to be true okay
somebody just asked and chat so s is the
partial order well almost
so we just said what is a partial order
it's two things glued together
so a partial order is a set together
with a binary relation
so the partial order in this case
is the combination of s
and this binary relation on elements of
s
so we could write it like a pair like
this
and then what about the last part of
transitivity well
in this case transitivity would be
something like well
the set containing a is a subset of the
set containing a and b
the set containing a and b is a subset
of the set containing a b
and c therefore we can put those two
pieces together and get
that the set containing a is a subset of
the set containing a b
and c
so we got all three we have that this
particular partial this particular
binary relation
is reflexive anti-symmetric and
transitive
so that means that we have a partial
order
now notice that not everything
here is comparable right by the
by the relation so in other words
if i were to just take the set
containing a
and the set containing b neither of
those is
uh is a subset of the other
so you're going to have some elements in
general in a partial order you may have
elements that are not comparable like
this
so what does that have to do with us
well
for us when we're talking about
our favorite relation that happens
before relation
elements that are not comparable are
exactly the ones
that the happens before relation says
are concurrent so if we go back
to the picture that we were showing a
second ago
of a whole bunch of events that happen
in an execution of a distributed system
like we said some of these events are
going to be concurrent like a and d
for example so those are events that
aren't ordered by the partial order
a total order is different if you have a
total order
then every pair of events is ordered
but we don't have that here instead we
have a partial order
i'll bring back this picture for a
second
so this is a real genuine example of a
partial order
that has all the properties reflexivity
anti-symmetry and transitivity
and that happens before a relationship
is just a little different
because it doesn't have that reflexivity
property
so what happens before relationship is
what we call an irreflexive partially
but in every other way it's a partial
leader
questions about this
okay let's come back to our definition
of what happens before relation here it
is one more time
it's just a pictorial definition but i
think that's good enough for us
so if a and b are events in the same
process and
a comes before b on that process then we
have a it happens before b
if a is ascend and b is the receive that
goes with it then a happens before it
before b
and then the transitivity part so
if a happens before c and c happens
before b and a happens before b
ah there were a couple of good questions
just now in chat so one person
asked what's the difference between a
partial order and a partially ordered
set
uh there's not really a difference so a
partial order like we said
is a set together with a binary relation
right so
partially ordered set
same thing and sometimes people call it
a poset
for short which just means partially
ordered set
so same thing it's a set together with a
relation
that lets you compare elements of that
set
but as we saw maybe not all the elements
are comparable
and somebody just somebody else asked uh
could i reiterate the difference between
a partial order and a total order well
going back to this picture of our
example
of a partial order which was set
containment that we just saw
notice that there are some elements of s
here like pick out these two elements
for example the set containing a and the
set containing b
um that aren't comparable according to
this
uh this binary relation so we can't say
that a is a subset of b
nor can we say that b is a subset of a
so that can happen in a partial order
where some
elements may not be comparable on the
other hand if it's a total order
every element is going to be comparable
what's an example of a total order
can somebody give me one
what's an example that's uh what's the
simplest example that you can think of
of something that's totally ordered
the alphabet okay
is that containing one element yeah
so the example that i was going to go
with was the natural numbers which
somebody just mentioned so
if i were to try to order the natural
numbers
if i were to draw a picture
they just go in a straight line right
so there's not any situation where you
have two numbers and it's like oh well
um these are not comparable right it's
always going to be the case
that if you pick out two numbers
from the set of natural numbers um you
know any n
m either
uh if they're different right
um
then either n is going to be less than m
or
m is going to be less than n right
that's always going to be true
it's a total order so there's no
ambiguity there
um or even if they're not distinct right
then this is true so
that's different from a partial order
where you may have some elements that
are not comparable that way and
our favorite example of that is in a
distributed execution where you have a
bunch of events
you might not be able to say that
one event happens before the other um
nor can you say the reverse so that's
exactly the situation where events are
concurrent
and so you don't have this total order
of events in a distributed execution
unless you do something more to try to
impose it
okay so this leads into our next topic
so last time we talked about clocks
right
and in particular we mentioned a couple
of different kinds of
physical clocks
so physical clocks encompass
time of day clocks
and monotonic clocks
but we also talked about problems with
using physical clocks
so what did we say that the alternative
was to using physical clocks
logical clocks that's right
so let us speak no more of physical
clocks
so this is an entirely different notion
of clock
they will not tell us anything about
time of day and they will not tell us
anything about time elapsed
instead they will only tell us about the
ordering of events
so we're going to be talking about a
couple of different kinds of logical
clocks
the simplest kind of logical clock that
i'm aware of
is called a lampwork clock
and a lampwork clock is just a way of
assigning numbers to events
in a distributed execution so
the notation that we'll use for this is
if you have an event
let's say event a then the lan port
clock
of this event is going to be written lc
of a
like this
so what is what is a language clock what
do they mean what do lymphoclex tell you
well a lampper clock is going to be some
integer actually a natural number that's
going to be assigned to an event
um so a lymph clock might be three for
instance
so let's say that the lamp clock of a is
three
what does that mean what does that three
tell you well
here is the rule
this is called the clock condition
if a happens before b
then the lampwork clock of a
is less than the lampwork clock of b
so this is the the happens before
relation that we've been talking about
and this is lamport clocks
so we say that lamport clocks
are consistent
with
causality
that means that if there is a causal
relationship between a and b
that is if they happen before b that's
what it means for us
then we know that the language clock of
a is going to be less than the language
clock of b
so let's put a whole bunch of events up
and try to assign landmark clocks to
them
let's stick with our three machines
so here's the algorithm for assigning
language clocks to events
first
every process has to keep a counter
initialize to zero
second
on every event on a process that process
is going to increment its counter by one
third step is when you send a message
you need to include whatever your
current counter is along with the
message
what do you think step four is going to
be
i'll give you a hint it starts when
receiving a message
what do you think happens then
good yeah so presumably it's going to
have something to do with that
counter that got included with a message
when it got sent right
in step three if a process is going to
be including a counter value along with
the message it's sending then presumably
that has to get used somehow on the
receiving end
so that's exactly what's going to happen
so the receiver
is going to do the following
when receiving a message a process
sets its counter
to the maximum
of the local
and the received counters
plus one
let's work through all of these events
up here using this algorithm
so every process has to keep a counter
initialize to zero
i guess i won't call it x i'll call it
uh lc
okay what happens first well
m0 is sending a message here that's an
event
right so what does m0 have to do
right so this is an event so following
step two here
this process has to increment its
counter by one so its counter is going
to become
one and it's going to
include that clock value
along with the message we get here to
and i'll just put one right here to say
that that's the language clock value of
this event
we get here to machine one
machine one receives the message
what does it do well its current
blank clock value is zero it's getting a
message here with a lan port clock value
of one
which one's bigger well one is bigger
than zero
right so it's going to compare the two
it's going to pick the one that's bigger
that's this max part down here
so we're taking the maximum of our local
uh lan port clock which was zero and the
received one which was one
so the bigger one was one and then we're
going to add one to that
so the lan port clock value now becomes
two
for this event and it's going to update
its local clock to that
what happens here for this next event on
m1 somebody tell me
yeah so process m1 or
machine 1 is going to go to 3.
this event gets a line for clock value
of 3 and that gets sent along
so here
machine 2 gets the message what does
machine 2 do
right so it's going to compare its local
lan port clock value
to the one that was just received which
was three
three is bigger than zero so three wins
and then we add one so this lamp clock
value of this event here is going to be
four
we're going to update this to four
and we keep going from here so this
event is another event on m2
so we get to increment there
that gets sent along here five minutes
here now we're comparing five to one
five is bigger than one so five wins and
then we improve it to bed
great we've just assigned landmark clock
values to all of the events in our
system
so we have this way of now assigning
numbers to events
and we know that if a happens before b
then the lampport clock of a
is less than the lampport clock of b
in other words lamport clocks are
consistent with causality
so let's take a quick look at this and
let's see if we think that's true
so well
this event here we know happened before
this one right because they're on the
same process line and
indeed one is less than six
likewise this event here happened before
this one right because
this one is ascend and this is the
corresponding receive and indeed when we
look at the landmark clocks we see that
three is less than four so if you look
at any pair of events here you'll see
that
if a happened before b then the lampwork
clock of a will be less than the input
clock
b so it checks out
and it's what we want it's consistent
with causality
by the way in some formulations of this
algorithm
uh you'll see it done differently so
sometimes message receives do not get
counted as events
so here we chose to count message
receives as events but
if you weren't counting message receives
as events
then you could do that um and if and
then
the algorithm would be the same except
that you wouldn't have to do this plus
one here
so if you've ever seen something like
this before and it didn't have the plus
one then that might be why
but we're today we're going to go with
this notion
of counting message receives as offense
and so
this is what the lancorp clock algorithm
would look like
okay so we have this nice property right
that if a happens before b
then the lampwork clock of a is less
than the length of clock of b
what about the other way around
if the lampro clock of a is less than
length or clock of b do we know that a
happens before b
in general
we actually don't so it's a little bit
of a trick question because in this
picture
it happens to be the case that
whenever we have a lan port clock that's
that's less than another lan port clock
like
say four and six for example four is
less than six and it happens to be the
case
in this particular picture that
for all the pairs where that's the case
we can also look back and say
the one with langford clock of four
happened before the one with land park
conference six and so on
but perhaps surprisingly it turns out
that this is not the case in general
so here's an example
so let's say again that we have three
machines
and we'll do another lane port diagram
let's do it like this
okay so let's walk through the steps of
the landford clock algorithm again and
let's try
to assign language clocks to all of the
events here
so in case you still need it here's the
lanport clock algorithm i'll put it like
that
hopefully you can see most of this
picture here so above this is just the
uh
names of the three processes like that
so nothing's really
being hidden from you here
okay so we want everybody to keep a
counter right that's initialized to zero
so
so let's start out let's just start
trying to assign line four clocks to
these events
so this one here on m1
is the first event happening on this
process
so it should get an increment so
that becomes one lane per clock at this
event is one and then that gets sent
along
what happens over here this is m2 well
we're going to compare zero with one one
is winning and then we add one to that
so the lan port clock value of this
event is two
what happens next here on m2
oops i forgot to update this here yep so
this events like clock value is three
three gets sent along with the message
all the way over to n zero
m zero is going to compare the three
with zero three is going to win
because it's bigger so then they'll
import clock value oops but we forgot
something because there was an internal
event up here
so internal events count two so this is
also going to get a link
or actually let me ask you what's going
to be the lan port clock value of this
event up here
this is the very first event on process
m0 happens to be an internal event but
it doesn't really matter uh so what's
the lane pro clock value of that event
going to be
one good so that's going to be the
lymphoid quote value there
now we get to this event here
i'll try to fit this all on the in view
so what's going to happen
when machine 0 receives this message
with a lan court clock value of 3 and it
compares to its own
lan port clock
right so three is bigger than one
so the lan port clock of that event will
be four here's another internal event so
that one gets five
coming back over here to machine 2
what's going to be the lan port clock
value of of this event right here
i think i'll move the rules out of the
way because i think we all pretty much
know what they are now
so what's going to be the link or clock
value of this one
that one's going to be 4 good 4 is going
to get sent along
we'll come here machine one
whoops i forgot to update these over
here
uh machine one had a lane port clock
value of one before that's going to get
compared with four
out of one and four four wins and then
we add one to that so that's going to
have
five
here's the next event on m1 that one's
going to be six
and finally six gets centered on here
and our very last one we have six here
we have five here
six and five get compared and six is
bigger than five so six wins and then we
add one to that
okay so we've assigned landmark clock
values to all of the events in this
execution according to the algorithm
that we just gave so let me draw your
attention to a particular pair of events
here
let's look at this one here a let's call
it a
and let's look at this one here which
i'll call b
so the land port clock of a here is one
and the lampwork clock of b is five
but did a happen before b
so here's a trick for knowing whether
one event on a lan port diagram happened
before another one
on a lan port diagram if you can reach
b from a then you know what happened
before b
so if i can follow lines from a to get
to b
then i know that a happened before b but
that's not the case here
right if i were to start at a
and follow arrows i cannot get to b
i could start here and get to b
or here or here
uh but i can't get there from here right
so in this picture you cannot reach
event b from event
of n a so you cannot say that a happened
for b even though
its landmark clock is bigger
so even though
we have this thing that says that
if a happened before b
then the lamproot clock of a is less
than the language clock of b
it's not the case
that
if the lampwork clock of a is less than
the length of b
then a happens before you
so somebody asked a question a little
while ago
uh on zulip about uh about really what
we mean by
causality like when i say a
arrow b like this somebody asks does
this mean a caused b
or does it mean or does it just mean a
happen before b or what well
good question what it means is that a
potentially comes to b
so it didn't necessarily cause it but we
say
potentially caused we can certainly say
happened before
whether it actually caused this event
whether it actually caused me is another
question
uh but you know that it could have been
a cause so that's why we say potential
causality
thanks for asking that one
so i think part of the reason you were
asking that is because
a little while ago when i wrote this
down
uh i wrote the lanport clocks are
consistent with causality
so if i wanted to be really pedantic
about it
i could say language clocks are
consistent with potential causality
so because of what i just showed coming
back to this picture
where we assigned blackboard clocks to
all these events but we found that
even though this lampert clock of this
event here is bigger than this one
that doesn't mean that this one happened
before this one
so we say that although line part clocks
are what we call consistent
with causality or consistent with
potential causality
we say that landmark clocks do not
characterize causality
so mathematically speaking
consistent with causality
or potential causality if you want to be
precise about it means
if a happens before b then
the logical clock
of a is less than the logical clause
philosophy
that's what it would mean to be
consistent with causality and landmark
clocks have this property
yay but another desirable property is
what we call
characterizes causality
and that means that
if the logical clock
of a is less than the logical clock of b
then a happens before b
and lan port clubs do not have this
property
sad face
so it's a little bit of a bummer right
lamport clocks are
pretty convenient in the sense that it's
pretty easy to run that
those out those steps of that algorithm
that i gave a minute ago it's pretty
easy to assign lan port clocks to events
so it sure would be nice if we had both
ways of this relation here it would be
really nice if important
were both consistent with causality and
if they characterize causality
sadly that's not true so
what good are they then somebody just
asked this great question in zulu what's
the point of lingport clocks
so what could we still use them for well
why would you ever want to use them well
we do know this right
we have that if a happens before b then
the logical quote of a is less than the
logical clock with b
so this is a logical implication
what's something that you can do with an
implication
anytime you have a logical implication
what's something you can do with it
now i mean like some people are laughing
at this question about so what's the
point of lymphoid clocks but that's
a damn good question right what is the
point
well here's what you can do with an
implication
anytime
anytime you have an implication like p
implies q like this
you can take what's called its
contrapositive
so if p in plays q in this case that
means that
not q implies not
p so this notation here means
not for those unfamiliar
so that's kind of nice so that's
something that you can do so
coming back to the import clocks well
the implication that we had was this
right we had
a happens before b implies
that the land port clock of a is less
than the language
of b well if we plug that in here
then we have this is p
and this is q right so here's our q
here's our p so then if we have if it's
not the case
that the lampport clock of a
is less than the important plot of v
then it's not the case that a happens
before b
and this is still pretty useful
information so
if it's not the case that the landmark
clock of a is less than the length of
b then we can rule out the possibility
that a happens before b now
that doesn't tell us everything we might
want to know right
we still don't know exactly what the
relationship is here so it might be the
case that
no b happens before a or it might be the
case that a
and b are concurrent we don't know which
it is
but that's still pretty nice to know
it's nice to know that it
couldn't possibly be the case that a
happens before b
in this situation if we use the counter
clockwise so that's what my port clocks
can be used for
they can rule out things as not having
caused other things
it's still not everything that you might
want to know
but it's nice and it's fairly easy to
compute
so if you look at what we did in this
figure here
when we were assigning lamport clocks to
all these events
this is a pretty low overhead algorithm
right
all the additional information that we
had to tack on to these messages as they
were getting sent around here
was one number so that's really nice
right if you only have to tack on one
number
then that's not too much overhead
and it may not tell you everything that
you want to know
but in distributed systems everything is
a trade-off
right if you wanted to know more you
would need to pass around more
information
and that would cause you to use up more
bandwidth
and it might not be worth it honestly so
lampard clocks are pretty nice
because they're a little overhead way to
get some information
about the ordering of events and that's
nice
so that's what lanport clocks are for
they were invented by leslie lamport
who i mentioned on day one of class
is the father of distributed systems uh
in a paper that was published in 1978
and you can go look it up yourself if
you want um look up lanport 1978 the
paper is called time clocks and the
ordering of events in a distributed
system
so this paper is parts of this paper
remain deeply relevant today other parts
of it are not so relevant
but it's it's considered one of the
highlights of the distributed systems
literature of all time
so it's a fun one to look at if you're
interested in some historical
perspective
all right so i goofed
and i didn't set up a quiz for today
my excuse is that i just got my first
vaccine shot
yesterday and so my arm really hurts and
and uh i'm i'm not thinking straight so
i failed to set up a quiz for today but
i still think that you deserve your
10-minute break
so we're going to take our 10-minute
break and when we come back from our
break
uh we will talk about a different kind
of logical cloth
that in fact not only
is consistent with causality but also
characterizes causality unlike
length of clocks so let's do our 10
minute break starting now i'll set a
timer and
when we come back we'll talk about a
different kind of logical clock see you
in 10 minutes
do
okay fine a equals b a is b
a yeah
that's true i did not define equality
sure yeah
hmm
yeah in fact the lsd seminar was
attended by a few students from our
class last week
so hopefully we'll get even more this
next time
i think you were
yep
uh let me take a look
yeah so patrick the only uh change i
would make would be to say
uh for partial order the binary relation
may only be defined for some pairs
so a total order is also a partial order
it's just the special case of partial
order where in fact you
have the relation defined for every pair
so every total order is also a partial
order but not every partial order is a
total order does that make sense
right
uh-huh i think so
all right we're going to start again in
a minute
all right one minute is up
hope everybody got a chance to get their
eyes away from the screen
i really do mean it when i tell people
to get eyes away from the screen
it's not enough of a break for your eyes
to just look at something else on the
screen you should really look away from
the screen
otherwise it's just more stress for your
eyes
all right so we just got done talking
about lane port clocks
and we said
that the relationship between lane port
clocks and the happens before relation
is this
in other words lamport clocks are
consistent with causality
and the other direction
the characterizes causality direction
the direction that would go like this
is not true
so it sure would be nice if we had some
kind of logical clock
that did exactly characterize causality
it did characterize the happens before
relationship
happily it exists and it gets used
all the time in distributed systems it's
called a vector clock
so here's the property that's true of
vector plots
or if a happens before b
then the vector clock of a is less than
the vector clock of b
and also if the vector clock of a is
less than the vector clock of b
then a happens before b so that's if and
only if this time
we have both directions of this
implication not just if
like we had before but if and only if
this is big this means that
vector clocks are consistent with
causality
and characterized causality
okay so how do they work what's the
definition of a vector
well remember a lampard clock is just an
integer
right that's associated with an event so
given the name vector clocks what do you
suppose a vector clock is
a clock using vectors okay that's one
answer
um well if a landform clock is just one
integer
a vector clock is going to be a vector
of integers
so this is the way that it works
first of all
we're going to say that every process
keeps a vector
of integers initialized to zero
how many do you think how big is this
vector going to be
good yeah the suggestion is as many
entries as we have processes that's
exactly right
so there's going to be one entry in this
vector for every process
good so if you had three processes
then every processes vector clock would
start out like this zero zero zero
initially okay so
just like with lan port clocks that we
just saw we're going to use vector
clocks to count events
but they're going to be more informative
than lan port plots
so next part of the definition
on every event
process increments
its own position
and its vector clock
i wrote integers here but they could
really just be natural numbers
they're never going to go negative
by the way when i say on every event
this includes internal events as well as
well as sends and receives
so
all events sends receives and internal
events
next up when sending a message
the process includes
its current vector clock
so just like we saw with lan port clocks
a little while ago
with lampwork clocks when you send a
message you're going to attach the
lancome clock to it
same with vector clocks when you send a
message you're going to attach
this extra thing to the message which is
your current vector clock
and this is going to happen after the
increment that happened in step two
because ascend is an event
okay that covers sending
what about receiving
this is the most interesting part
anybody have a guess at what what
happens with vector clocks when we
receive a message
indexing to the vector well that's
certainly going to be involved
it's right so you're getting a message
and it's got a vector clock attached to
it right
you've got to do something with that
vector clock that you're receiving
right and somehow it's probably going to
involve comparing that to whatever
electric clock you have yourself
so what will we do well
when receiving a message process will
update
to the maximum
of the local vector clock and the
received vector clock
so this is its own
and this is the vc that was on the
message
and it's also going to increment its own
position and its vector clock according
to sub 2 because receiving is also an
event
so this is all going to happen just like
here we're going to say
because receives our events
so that's the vector clock algorithm
hmm somebody just asked a question so
they said
wait but on the lan port diagram don't
we end up with a vector at the end as
well so i think they were talking about
with lan port clocks so this is a little
different
with lan port clocks every event
is going to get associated with just a
single number
so if you wanted to right you could
think of um
the lan port clock of every process
right and
and put them together and think of that
being a vector
but this is going to be a little
different in this case instead of just
keeping one number
every process is going to keep a vector
and every event is going to get
associated with effect
ah so there was just a question is step
four element wise right
so we're doing this max operation here
on vectors but we haven't defined what
it means to take the maximum of vectors
so let's do that now
so if somebody just correctly
anticipated in chat it's going to be
pointwise maximum so for instance if i
have two vectors and they're let's say 1
12 and 4 and
say 7 0 and 2
then what's the maximum of those two
going to be
good yeah
so it's going to be what's called point
wise maximum or element-wise maximum
okay good
so coming back to this vector clock's
algorithm here
we only have three more minutes for
today so we're going to have to save
an example run of this algorithm for
next time
uh but let's talk a little bit just
about what this means
so we said that
with lan port clocks
we're using them to count events that
happen right
but we get more information out of
vector clocks than we do out of blank
flip flops so for example
if the land port clock of an event is
just say
the number five then all that tells you
is
five events have occurred including
this event that has the clock value of
five that's all it tells you five events
of the card it doesn't say anything
about
where those events might have occurred
it just says that five events have
occurred
but if you had a vector clock
for example like if you had five zero
zero
so let's say that these are entries in
this vector clock are each representing
alice bob and carol
this vector clock of five zero zero
describes a world
in which alice has seen five events
and bob and carol haven't seen any or
another way to put that
is it's a world where we know about five
events that have happened on alice and
we don't know about any events that have
happened about
uh happened for bob and carol so this
gives us more information than just the
plain old number five and it turns out
that this additional information is
going to be exactly what we need to know
to get that characterization of
causality that we wanted
to have out of logical clocks
so sadly we're almost out of time and
we're going to have to
save an example run of this vector
clocks algorithm for next time
and next time we're also going to talk
more about how you compare vector clocks
which is kind of related to what i just
said about the max operation
but that will have to stay be saved for
next time
in the meantime
i know that you're hard at work on
assignment one some people have
uh already started forming their teams
for assignment two and beyond
remember that you need to do that by
friday and if you have questions about
assignment one please please please ask
them on zulu
also be sure to go to section so i know
a lot of people got a lot out of going
to patrick's section
yesterday and abhay has his section
tomorrow
so that's a great place to go if you
have questions about the homework
uh otherwise keep asking questions on
zulic
talk to us if you need help and remember
to get your team together
alright i will see you on thursday
take care
you